[Musique]
bonsoir madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur je vous parle pour la
première fois comme candidat à la
présidence de la république
je me suis déjà dressé à vous vous en
souvenez pour vous commenter la
situation économique de la france
lorsque j'avais la responsabilité de
l'économie et que je travaillais aux
côtés du président georges pompidou
mais maintenant il s'agit une autre
fonction la présidence de la république
et d'un autre sujet la politique de la
france
j'ai dit que pendant cette campagne je
voulais regarder la france au fond des
yeux la france pour moi qu'est ce que
c'est c'est l'ensemble de toutes celles
et de tous ceux qui habitent qui
grandissent qui travaillent qu'ils
vieillissent sur notre sol et donc pour
moi la france c'est chacune et chacun
d'entre vous et c'est pourquoi je vous
regarde ce soir et c'est pourquoi aussi
vous ne regardez vous allez choisir
votre président c'est à dire l'homme qui
exercera les plus hautes responsabilités
et queralt devoir de conduire la france
dans des circonstances prévisible mais
aussi de faire face à l'imprévu et qui
parlera à votre nom votre nom dans le
monde moderne pour choisir ce président
vous poser je pense deux questions qui
choisir et le choisir pour quoi faire
d'abord qui choisir
quand on se présente pour un emploi
n'importe quel emploi quand on se
présente pour un travail n'importe quel
travail on vous demande qui êtes vous et
c'est pourquoi lorsqu'on se présente à
cette fonction qui est la plus
importante des fonctions de la vie
française il faut dire qui on est aussi
au cours de ma prochaine édition qui
aura lieu lundi soir et qui sera la
dernière de la soirée
j'essaierai de vous dire qui je suis et
pourquoi je me présente à la présidence
de la république qui choisir
mais pour quoi faire et c'est ici que se
pose la question du programme concernant
le programme je voudrais rappeler que le
président des républicains en france des
pouvoirs très important les plus
importants mais qu'il ya aussi un
gouvernement qui a ses responsabilités
et qu'il ya aussi un parlement qui a ses
droits
et c'est pourquoi il s'agit moins de
programmes que de perspectives dans
quelle direction le président se
propose-t-il de conduire d'orienter
d'entraîner la france pour moi ces
perspectives sont les suivantes
l'indépendance et la puissance pour la
france la justice et la sécurité pour
les français et pour la politique
française
le changement sans le risque de mort
pour la france l'indépendance et la
puissance
la france n'est pas un des plus grands
pays du monde mais c'est un grand pays
et elle a le droit de décider elle même
où elle veut aller et comment elle veut
d'y aller si la france veut être
indépendante elle doit se donner le
moyen de cette indépendance est à dire
la puissance et notamment la puissance
moderne qui vous le savez bien celle de
l'économie la france est un pays
indépendant
mais ce n'est pas un pays solidaire nous
faisons partie d'un ensemble
l'europe dont nous avons le devoir
d'organiser l'union au cours des
prochaines années pour aboutir en 1981
pour les français la justice et la
sécurité au cours des dernières années
beaucoup de choses ont été accomplies et
d'ailleurs il suffit de se souvenir si
peu que ce soit de ce qu'était la france
il ya quinze ans où il ya dix ans pour
le savoir mais il est vrai que notre
société n'est pas encore une société
juste et il est vrai que les français
n'ont pas encore vis-à-vis des risques
de la vie économique la sécurité à
laquelle ils ont droit
c'est pourquoi nous devons faire de la
société française une société plus juste
plus fraternelle plus égale et nous
devons concernant la sécurité sécurité
des travailleurs pour citer de l'emploi
sécurité des personnes âgées au point de
vue des ressources de la caisse sécurité
devant les épreuves de la vie et
notamment la maladie
nous devons accroître et garantir la
sécurité des français
je vous parlerai de l'ensemble de ces
questions au cours de mes prochaines
émissions et je consacrerai mon émission
la plus importante aux problèmes de la
vie quotidienne des français enfin pour
la politique française
le changement sans le risque le
changement pourquoi parce que le monde
change parce que le temps change parce
que vous enlevez et que la politique
française doit s'adapter à ce changement
les français le savent mais ils ont une
certaine inquiétude sur les conséquences
du changement
c'est pourquoi je vous propose le
changement sans le risque est maintenant
je voudrais vous demander quelque chose
il faut m'aider je n'ai pas la
prétention et je n'ai même pas le désir
de gagner seul ou de gouverner seul
j'ai le désir de gagner et de gouverner
avec l'appui avec le soutien avec la
confiance des françaises et des français
c'est pourquoi il faut m'aider madame
mademoiselle monsieur je compte sur vous
pour que le jour venu vous puissiez
compter sur moi
[Musique]
mais c'est le président il ya une
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
depuis bien longtemps
est ce qu'il est possible quand on
occupe des fonctions de garder le
contact avec les français de savoir
qu'ils sont de savoir ce qu'ils pensent
et de percevoir vraiment ce qu'ils
attendent de leur président je pense que
c'est possible
de toute façon c'est un problème qui
serait le même pour tout président
d'abord on dispose de beaucoup
d'informations
les mêmes d'informations que tous les
français puisque le matin au réveil on
écoute la radio on lit les journaux je
regarde la télévision générale à à
l'heure du déjeuner et je reçois donc
les mêmes informations que les français
ensuite à rien vous cacher non je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse cas ce que moi
que ce soit dans un monde où il ya
tellement d'informations
d'autre part yann et sur sa forêt sont
plus directs par exemple je reçois un
courrier j'ai reçu pendant mon septennat
1 million 400 mille lect de françaises
et de français et jean-louis d'abord
naturellement un grand nombre et ensuite
tous les mois j'ai une analyse de ces
lettres pour montrer les types de
préoccupation de la correspondance qu'il
en fait il ya une vie de famille
j'ai quatre enfants qui ont pour la vie
et celle de l'échangé le fil de leur âge
ils sont plus d'enfants sont nous
adolescents afin que l'on fait leurs
études pendant cette période quand tu es
dans les établissements d'enseignement
qui ont fait leur service militaire et
ainsi de suite donc qui apporte aussi le
les échos de la vie quotidienne des
français oui peut-être mais enfin au
fait que la plupart du temps on apprend
beaucoup de choses chez d'épicés ou en
allant acheter un paquet de cigarettes
que tabac du coin je voulais dire je n'y
allais pas tu n'achètes pas casquette le
public car que je peux vous dire par
exemple dimanche dernier nous rentrions
campagne avons eu une panne de nintendo
tôt une panne de des voyages alors nous
sommes allés en eau libre heureusement
jusqu'au prochain garage ça va les faire
réparer dans la voiture au garage et
dans la vie un courant et même beaucoup
d'occasions de rencontres avec les
françaises et les français dès le matin
se penche sur les promenades autour de
l'elysée et j'envoie et il est de dire
bonjour nous parlons des échanges en
quelques réflexions et enfin une chose
c'est que je suis quelqu'un qui regarde
beaucoup il ya eu une information par le
regard quand vous circulez dans la ville
quand vous regardez les visages des
saints des joueurs que vous participe à
des réunions et moi c'est par le regard
que j'observe au bout j'imagine que vous
tenez compte de ce que vous êtes cernés
j'essaie d'en tenir compte
on était votre question est plutôt
j'imagine de dire n'est ce pas est ce
que on peut sentir
on sait est-ce qu'on peut sentir à cause
de la ville très particulière qu'on mène
alors sur cette ville je dirais ceci
pour le mon prochain septennat si je
suis élu trois fois distingué tout à
fait deux choses il ya la vie officielle
la vie officielle d'un président de
république française elle doit être
marquée par la dignité parce que nous
sommes en pays un ancien pays
et puis il ya la vie personnelle elle
doit être aussi simple que possible mais
je suis forcé je m'efforcerai davantage
encore
alors vous êtes salle écoute des femmes
bien sûr vous avez fait de la condition
féminine
une des priorités à notre arrivée à
l'elysée est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que tout ou à peu près
effet en ce qui concerne la condition
féminine ou est ce que vous pourriez
faire encore plus des choses dont on
doit faire plus froid que l'idée le
message est passé
c'est à dire que les femmes françaises
doivent avoir une place importante dans
la société france je crois que ce
message est passé il ya encore quelques
années il était contestée où on lui
disait du bout des lèvres
donc le message est passé je crois
également qu'un certain nombre de choses
importantes ont été entreprises
concernant la condition féminine donc il
ya eu des progrès mais je crois qu'il y
a davantage encore à faire sur le point
suivant
au début comme il s'agissait de quelque
chose de nouveau qui était cet exercice
des responsabilités par les femmes
on a peut être trop mis l'accent
justement sur ce seul aspect exercice
des responsabilités vie professionnelle
des femmes et je souhaite maintenant
qu'on mette un peu plus l'accent sur le
problème de la compatibilité entre la
vie professionnelle des femmes et la vie
de famille comment les femmes
peuvent-elles à la fois avoir une vie
professionnelle à laquelle elle aspire
et à mon avis tout aspirant on va voir
une certaine vie propre et la ville
sammy alors deux idées là-dessus
d'une part le développement du travail à
temps partiel qui ne doit pas être une
règle mais qui est une possibilité
et pour lequel savez j'ai prévu un grand
développement travaillent à temps
partiel qui doit s'accompagner d'une
carrière
naturellement et puis également le
problème de l'éducation des très jeunes
enfants c'est-à-dire avant la maternelle
c'est tellement agréable d'élever son
enfant pendant quelques mois au joker
je pense que c'est le désir profond de
beaucoup de femmes entrent dans que des
enfants jusqu'à deux ou trois ans avant
l'arrivée
alors là il ya probablement des formules
d'avoir d'organisation qu'on peut
trouver et puis aussi un problème de
ressources et je crois que nous devons
créer un type de ressource pour les
jeunes femmes qui pendant cette période
choisie c'est d'élever l'enfant pourrait
presque appeler ça un salaire voilà le
mot ne m'effraie pas c'est une ressource
mais en face vous laisser cette y ait
enfin un cycle pour le fameux rendez
vous avez une chose si vous me permettez
étages et un secret avec les femmes
françaises peut dire que si j'ai tâché
tellement d'importance pour une raison
profonde et ce secret je dirais un peu
plus aujourd'hui sur l'eau va vous aider
vous avez cherché aussi à réduire les
inégalités
naturellement on a vu ça en ce qui
concerne les personnes âgées c'est très
important mais je voudrais vous dire une
chose il ya une catégorie de français
qui se sent un peu mal aimé je vais vous
dire qu'ils se sont ce qu'on appelle les
français moyens mais c'est pas péjoratif
du tout un moyen je dire ce sont les
employés de bureau voyez les gens qui
vont bureau tous les matins tous les
après midi qu'ils rentrent chez eux à
18h le soir et tout ça qui ont pas une
vie très drôle qui gagne 1 très mal leur
vie mais juste un tout petit peu au
dessus du plafond et qui donc ne peuvent
pas bénéficier de certaines prestations
sociales qui sont bien utiles aux autres
qu'il faut que les autres continuent à
voir mais ils ne peuvent pas les avoir
alors est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas
quelque chose à faire pour cela est ce
que vous me reposez à une question sur
les personnes âgées
si vous voulez quinze siècles parlons
d'abord de ces non ce ne sont pas des
mal aimés ils ont ce chantier
oui mon sentiment pourquoi d'abord parce
que c'est une catégorie qui est la plus
nombreuse
actuellement des français le travail
semaines maintenant plus l'ombre
légèrement plus nombreux que les
ouvriers et ils voient que dans les
grands débats sociaux on s'occupe moins
deux que des pourquoi c'est en effet
parce commission dans une situation
moyenne et qu' il fallait corriger les
grandes injustices et les grands à du
injustice étaient tous debout qui se
sont dit on ne s'occupe pas de nous et
d'autre part pour corriger certaines de
ces grandes injustices et notamment tout
ce qui était les basses rémunérations
on a créé des avantages sociaux pour les
catégories qui avaient déplu petite
rémunération qui ne se sont pas
impliqués ou imparfaitement appliquée à
ces catégories moyennes
par exemple un certain type de logement
certaines prestations même familial ont
des plafonds qui font qu'ils ne
bénéficient pas et ils ont ce sentiment
donc d'être malgré quelques fois le
plafond est et ce qu'il gagne c'est
cette optique à différents salons je
voulais je crois je lui en ai parlé
l'autre jour je pense à préparer à lille
en effet cette catégorie très importante
et ça devient de plus en plus la partie
centrale de la france alors je pense que
ce que nous devons faire c'est ceci est
il fallait faire l'effort pour les
catégories les plus défavorisées il
fallait le faire mais ayant consacré des
ressources à cet effort il faut
maintenant voir si ce qui a été fait
pour les catégories moyennes n'est pas
dans une certaine mesure trop peu
injuste en 4 op 3 et regarder au point
de vue précisément de de l'aide au
logement à l'accession à la propriété
tous les questions de plafonds de
ressources si nous ne devons pas revoir
ces plafonds de ressources
éventuellement supprimer certains
d'entre eux une autre question
importante c'est que je suis partisan
pour ces catégories du maintien de ce
qu'on appelle le quotient familial dans
la peau il ya des candidats mais ça qui
propose la suppression du quotient
familial
je suis contre cette suppression parce
que ce serait la même chose on
commencerait par mettre un plafond qui
serait assez ou naturellement on dirait
aux catégories moyennes ça ne vous
concerne pas et puis avec l'évolution la
hausse des prix ainsi de suite les
catégories moyennes seraient atteintes
donc voyez ce que je veux dire réviser
les plafonds de ressources pour leur
donner accès à certaines facilités ou à
certaines prestations maintien du
quotient familial
les personnes âgées vous avez fait
beaucoup de choses pour elle n'est pas
encore bien sûr l'idéal étant donné que
l'idéal pourrait être quelque chose de
bien plus important
ce que je sais c'est que ces personnes
âgées souvent ont des problèmes parce
qu'elles ont des petites économies
qu'elle placé des petites économies ça
apporte pas grand-chose et quelquefois
face c'est tout sous de taux d'inflation
et les personnages et c'était un des
grands efforts pas personnel c'est moi
qui conduis tout seul c'était fort
c'était un effort national en pendant
sept ans la progression du niveau de vie
des personnes âgées qui était à la
correction d'une grande injustice a
représenté une dépense supplémentaire
par rapport à la simple poursuite de ce
qu'on faisait avant de 50 milliards de
francs que les français on
apportez saïdia est énorme alors d'abord
cet effort sera poursuivi
elles se disent on a parlé de nous dans
le passé on parle maintenant de la
jeunesse est ce qu on va l'oublier on va
naturellement poursuivre l'effort c'est
à dire la progression du pouvoir d'achat
les personnes âgées et notamment du
minimum vieillesse
deuxième sujet je crois que nous
lancerons d'inspiration c'est de rester
chez elle c'est le problème du maintien
domicile alors il ya beaucoup de
questions à cet égard aux aménagements
du logement aides à domicile et mon
objectif c'est qu'il y ait 50 % d'heures
de plus des domiciles dans le prochain
septennat pour permettre le maintien
chez elles les personnes âgées qui le
souhaitent
vous avez parlé de la question de l'
épargne à regarder à l'heure actuelle le
dernier emprunt d'état les emprunts
d'état ont les se sait que vous allez
partout dans tous les établissements on
l'a placé à un taux d'intérêt de 13,8
pour cent taux d'intérêt et la hausse
des prix à l'heure actuelle est encore
trop forte
bien sûr elle est comme vous avez vu un
peu supérieure à 12% et nous espérons
d'ailleurs en réduire le taux d'ici la
fin de l'année donc en par exemple en
souscrivant un emprunt on était protégé
contre les faux en fait il fallait
conseiller
il faut les conseillers il faut aussi je
vous dis je le sais j'en prends
l'engagement que toutes les émissions
tous les emprunts qu'ils sont faits
auprès du grand public est un taux
d'intérêt qui soit supérieur au taux
d'inflation
vous avez parlé notamment des jeunes
bien sûr on va y revenir aux jeunes mais
je voulais parler d'abord de la famille
on a un peu l'impression que les valeurs
familiales se perdent tout le monde son
plein autour de nous alors est ce que
vous croyez qu'il ressorte il est du
ressort du chef de l'état d' essayer de
redonner une espèce des longs en cette
matière et puis et puis aussi en ce qui
concerne la démographie on se plaint
qu'il y a de moins en moins d'enfants
mais c'est difficile matériellement
élever des enfants
matériellement et moralement la famille
s'est pas l'état et les pays dans lequel
la famille c'est l'état s'était et la
mort de la famille la famille est la
cellule de base de la société française
joly dit
plusieurs reprises j'ai la chance de
vivre dans une famille une grande chance
parce que vous aussi d'ailleurs
et quand on a cette chance on se rend
compte que ses supérieurs tout autre
chose dans la vie donc la famille boîte
est la cellule de base de la société
française elle a des problèmes matériels
on a cherché à les améliorer au cours
des dernières années et vous savez que
alors qu'avant dans la période de
prospérité il n'y avait pas progression
pouvoir d'achat des familles depuis 1974
deuxième effort de solidarité il a eu un
effort d une progression notoire d'achat
des familles ceux ci doivent poursuivre
avec un accent particulier pour les
familles de trois enfants et plus est
également il faut dire pour les femmes
qui élèvent de très jeunes enfants c'est
les deux situations qui semble
économiquement difficile parce que à
partir de 3 enfants on voit bien que la
charge que la dépense pour la famille et
tous croient tout de même beaucoup plus
rapidement et quant à la natalité vous
avez vu parce que c'est un signe de
vitalité français qu'en 1980 la natalité
à romain clean mais cela n'est pas
encore suffisant tout ça mais la
remontée
et comme on n'arrive pas à trouver des
explications détaillées de ce genre de
phénomène ça exprime en quelque sorte la
vitalité d'une société et ça prouve
qu'en 1981 la france a retrouvé
confiance en elle
mais dites moi ces jeunes qui vont
grandir chatte inquiète pour eux parce
que ce que je vois ce que je connais ce
que je fréquente et j'en vois beaucoup
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont coincés
qu'ils ont peur du chômage c'est un mot
qui revient toujours dans mes
conversations sont peur de l'échec
très difficile les études et puis ils
ont peur de la guerre comme l'étions
jeune moi c'était bien avant on avait
peur de la guerre et au fond c'était la
chose dont on avait peur
le problème de l'emploi ne se posait pas
dans les mêmes conditions vous souvenir
discuter en direct pour faire comme
métier les uns les autres
la question est de savoir si on aurait
la capacité d'accéder à ce métier nous
dire sur les accès non laurent alors à
l'heure actuelle et bien en corse et de
craintes il ya d'abord la crainte de la
guerre et je veux que la france reste un
pays qui lutte pour la paix que ce soit
un pays formé pacifique et je souhaite
la jeunesse française des buteurs dans
mes réunions combien l'applaudissait ce
thème que nous restons un pays qui se
bat pour la paix pour la question de
l'emploi j'ai présenté un certain nombre
de propositions vous avez vues
détaillées avec l'idée suivant
faire en sorte que d'ici 1985 tout jeune
française est tout jeune français qui
arrivent en âge de travail et se voit
offrir soit un poste de travail donc
soit un emploi soit la poursuite de sa
formation
parce que je souhaite que les jeunes
français et accède au travail avec un
niveau de formation élevé
donc il y à cette préoccupation de
l'emploi seront actionnés par la seule
préoccupation de la jeunesse c'est qu'on
aurait tort de croire qu'elle accélère
elle veut aussi je dirais avoir un rôle
faire quelque chose que sa vie est un
sens et c'est pourquoi dans je m'efforce
de deux de faire apparaître que la
france est un pays qui veut avoir une
vocation qui va faire quelque chose dans
le comment faire passer ce message là le
message passe je suis très frappé par
exemple josé du soutien que je dresse
apporter ma campagne et je suis très
frappé de voir que des thèmes comme par
exemple le tiers-monde
le fait que la france soit un pays
généreux qui agissent dans le monde 20
pire oubliées sont égoïstes
c'est un thème que je soutiens tout à
fait la jeunesse je veux que la france
la jeunesse française connaissent le
monde pour ça qu'elle parcourt le monde
autant que possible et je veux qu'elle
apparaisse comme jeunesse qui apportent
quelque chose donc vous voyez d'une part
président le problème de l'emploi et
d'autre part que des jeunes aient le
sentiment que leur vie à cette façon le
jury seront tranquilles sur le problème
de l'emploi leur vie aura en face que ce
n'est pas uniquement il faut non on peut
très bien avoir des sortes de sociétés
assoupli non il faut une société vivante
qui s'intéressent au problème du groupe
se monte en grandes transformations
auxquelles la france peut apporter
quelque chose
enfin une dernière question j'aimerais
que vous m'expliquer en détail ce que
vous avez voulu dire dans l'une de vos
dix propositions pas d'ailleurs ce
terrain 10e lorsque vous disiez la
france propre
les français par dans les français
propriétaires de la france moi j'adore
le mot propriétaire trouve sa
confortable mais le propriétaire de la
france est bien même je dis ceci jeudi
les français propriétaires individuels
de la france parce qu'il ya une forme
propriété la france qu'on pourrait
imaginer qu'ils seraient la propriété
collective ou et tactiques de la france
vous voyez quelle heure actuelle y un
rejet par les français des structures
étatiques ou trempe étatiques et donc ce
que je voudrais c'est que les français
et les françaises pour propriétaires
individuels de la france vous en avez
déjà beaucoup vous avez par exemple dans
l'agriculture en grand nombre
d'agriculteurs qui possèdent de leur
exploitation ou leur outil de travail
vous avez parmi les professionnels
parmi les commerçants les artisans
beaucoup de travailleurs qui supporte
d'ailleurs des risques importants et qui
sont propriétaires de leurs activités
économiques dues aux fonds de commerce
mais c'est vrai que c'est une règle
générale en france que chaque français
et chaque français se disent je possède
un bout de la france c'est très français
d'ailleurs comme sentiment je crois
parce que nous sommes un pays terrien
d'origine ou un pays rural ou pas nous
avons le sens de la propriété alors deux
cas deux exemples premier exemple le
l'actionnariat dans les entreprises il
est pour moi tout à fait si vous voulez
choquant que quelqu'un qui travaille
toute sa vie dans une entreprise dans
possèdent leur soutien vous avez vu ce
qui a été fait il a eu d'une part ce
qu'on appelle la loi monory pour
faciliter des achats d'actions francs
que ça concerne est largement plus d'un
million de personnes on a dû passer aux
alentours de 2 millions de personnes
il a eu la loi que j'ai proposé au
parlement qui l'a adoptée pour la
distribution d'actions aux salariés des
entreprises
distribution gratuite et j'ai eu des
résultats ce matin il y aura un million
cent mille bénéficiaires individuels
donc ça fait les familles en élite et
qui vont recevoir de ses actions ils
recevront chacun en moyenne aux environs
de 2400 francs d'actions de leur
entreprise ce n'est pas considérable
ils deviennent propriétaires autre
exemple le logement pour rappeler
qu'autrefois on construisait des grands
ensembles
car mon arrivée à l'elysée j'ai demandé
qu'on arrête cela et que l'on se tourne
vers la maison individuelle on a
construit en sept ans un million huit
cent quarante mille maisons
individuelles et je souhaite que la
proportion s'accroissent et pour
faciliter l'acquisition de ces maisons
j'ai proposé vous avez dû voir cela
aussi ce que j'ai appelé un plan dépeint
du propriétaire le vin plan
d'épargne-logement je souhaite un plan
dépend de propriété c'est-à-dire que les
gens puissent acquérir leur logement et
notamment leur premier logement en
particulier les jeunes que ce logement
soit 9 s'il veulent construire où que ce
soit déjà un logement existant s'ils
veulent améliorer ou utiliser un
logement existant pour que voit pas de
chaque français et chaque français se
disent j'ai les droits politiques en
france
un citoyen l'iodé rond le voit bien dans
la campagne on l'a même vu dans l'avant
campagne mais qu'ils se disent aussi je
participe la vie de la france je possède
mon morceau de la france donc c'est ça
que j'ai voulu dire les français
propriétaires individuels de la france
aujourd'hui nous avons parlé ensemble 1
p sont de la vie quotidienne des
français et demain je parlerai de la
place et du rôle de la france dans le
monde de la grandeur de la france à
leucan historiens arthur conte et je
vous remercie d'avoir bien voulu me
poser vos questions
[Musique]